all right we um
where are you from originally where do
you grow up so i grew up in morocco but
i am originally from libya and morocco
since my parents are half have oh
interesting
and you've been in the united states how
long i've been here since 2018. it's
going on three years now
and you're going to school at nyu i go
to school in parsons yes oh parsons yes
not nyu no i met you near nyu yes
which is also nearby yes and uh
you came to the united states for what
reason just to go to school so yes
exactly that um i decided to follow my
passion and i felt like this was the
place that i could do it the most
morocco didn't offer that no not for
women and not for my field
why is it different difficult why do you
say that for women
well
it sucks honestly for me to have to like
really go through this but it's
something that
it's a place that
women don't have much power because most
of the laws are against us and then the
mentality as well is just built to
keep women on
like
on the bottom
honestly yes and for me to start a
fashion brand for women
i
do not see how that's even possible in
morocco wow
so you've been in the united states for
three years you kind of ass i'm sure you
knew that the united states was a little
more
open to women and business and all that
yeah as well
opportunities here yes and it it also
felt like i was more free here uh even
as
somebody that is not from the united
states
um because i was able to step foot on
the streets and actually walk which i
have never done in morocco living there
for 18 years why is that
because there's constant fear that i'll
be attacked as a woman for what i'm
wearing for who i am and just simply for
being a woman
really yes i have never ever in my 18
years of living in morocco my whole
entire life i was born there have i ever
stepped out in the streets and walked
alone
for fear of violence or fear of violence
for fear of
the fact that i might dress just a
little bit different if i wear my heels
out in broad daylight that's already
taboo and
i just didn't feel safe i didn't feel
like i could express myself as a person
there
that's interesting and sad
so is it an adjustment to come to the
united states where you're so free to
dress and do what you like yes actually
it's interesting because
my fashion style is is very erratic uh
even for the united states and so it's
great for me to step out here and
actually be congratulated for what i'm
working especially in new york city in
new york city i get congratulated all
the time i get people stopping me and
telling me hey
you're doing this amazing and your walk
is
completing the look and i'm like thank
you because
i never had that opportunity i've never
been stopped in the street even for my
outfit i've never never experienced that
so coming here it was
almost mind-blowing yeah that creative
freedom oh my god along with the
free to be who you are yeah
yeah is not just liberating it's
mentally and physically it's it takes
off
a [ __ ] ton of breaks from your shoulders
you're happier here in the u.s
it's harder to say because again you're
separated from your family it is yeah
that's the thing you know you you have
your whole culture and everything behind
and don't get me wrong i love morocco
and i love the culture and i love the
food but
when it's not safe for somebody all of
that stuff is almost swept under the rug
how did your family feel about you
coming here
oh i was completely let go with that one
i told my parents i wanted to study in
the united states and they looked at me
like i was crazy
they were like it's too far and i don't
think we can like we can do that with
you like we don't want you to send you
somewhere so far away and i was like
this is this is what i need to do this
is what i need to do and so they give me
the ultimatum it's either you go and you
do this alone or you don't go at all and
i'm here so
do you have siblings yes i do two
siblings actually both older than me a
brother and a sister
and
funny enough the ultimatum wasn't given
to my brother he came to miami
and just that you can already sense the
sexism uh between
in my family yeah for a boy for a male
to come is different exactly because
he's supposedly
stronger and more independent and
more safe and
i i didn't understand that i really did
not are there a lot of women in morocco
that are just so repressed so held down
that
but but they want more for them for
themselves yes yeah i'm sure there must
be right the reason i am here is not
just simply to run away from
all of the restrictions that you know i
lived with in morocco no no no no no i'm
here to learn i am here to take back
i want to take back like that is my
number one goal in life is to be able to
help my fellow women in situations in
places where they can't just leave
and i can't live with myself coming here
having the ability being so grateful as
a third world country first generation
to come here
and just do nothing with it
i i just i can't live with myself if i
ever did that that's great yeah
do you have friends
yes actually i do i have a lot of
friends here
and um most of my friends are foreigners
as well took a lot of courage for you to
do it you did
knowing that you're coming to a new
country with probably no friends here
nothing
so you've been able to make friends and
yeah i came here and all i had was a
hotel room and four years
and
i had to figure out where i was staying
what life was like here um
how
to portray myself and my culture in a
way that i will get no hate but still
fit in and
and just all of the little logistics you
know and getting an apartment and a
lease and
what is all of that yeah that's part of
growing up too exactly you're in your
early 20s so everyone in the early 20s
is figuring out exactly and i was like
i'm i'm having fun right now doing all
of this stuff but i'm i'm also very
stressed and scared that i'm alone
completely alone you graduate when i
graduate well now because i'm medical
leave but i'm supposed to be graduating
this spring
um but it will be extended probably to
next december medical legal
so i'm on medical leave because i have
adhd and i had just discovered adhd this
year
i've lived with it i know i've lived
with it i've always been the problematic
child i've
always gotten shunned by my teachers
the only teacher i think that
in almost every year even though there
were different teachers it was my art
teacher my art teacher was the one that
kind of saw
who i was
and how my adhd was affecting me so
she would always
take me from other classes and just
shove me in the corner of her class you
know and be like hey
i got something to work for our teachers
are the best right
i had the same some not different
experience but but our teachers were
always the ones that were understood and
kind of
took you under their wing exactly and so
with that with her realizing that
i had adhd
she kind of put me on to the art world
and since then
my like life has had diverted completely
it took a different
you know like literally a different
route completely
so i started doing art and i started
experimenting with different mediums and
it i started finding my
safe space yeah
yeah art can be very therapeutic
especially for someone that can't
concentrate and only concentrate on one
thing me doing my art i'm in there for
six hours at a time and you can focus
completely yeah
completely which
to me is actually quite ridiculous i've
never been able to do that that's great
yeah
i'm like i'm the same way if you're
inspired
you're 100 focused and if you're not
it's good good luck good luck yes
exactly
so uh
after you graduate your plan is to stay
here in the us
my
you know my plan when i came here was
yes to to graduate and stay in the
united states and
hopefully commence whatever you know
i wanted to um
but
along the way i felt like that kind of
changed um
there's a lot of factors to this uh
i didn't understand school
as a whole
not just the
being smart enough to comprehend the
knowledge that's been given to me i can
do that but the the concept itself was
something that
i was just never able to wrap my mind
around um
[Music]
so i decided like i said that maybe i
wouldn't be finishing school
i wanted to apply all of
that
art that i learned throughout my
childhood to something directly and i
felt like it was almost necessary for me
to do that because i needed to find
myself i needed to know who i was
outside of the teaching they taught me
how to do art they taught me i had six
hour studio classes teaching art in a
school
i found very
it's like they're they turn everyone
into the same creature exactly and an
artist should be free to just do
whatever and go down whatever path road
they want exactly and and be individuals
in school trying to
it kind of does the opposite it dims
down everyone's spark yeah exactly
so i'm not saying school and i'll get
like crap for saying school is bad but
yeah but for artists it's hard that
individual spirit is something you need
to nurture exactly and if i'm unable to
nurture that spirit i'm unable to offer
the world who i really am i don't want
to be another person student that's been
conditioned to be a certain way to to
release the same line that almost every
person student has released in fashion
or released the same collection in art
or released the same music in in jazz i
i just
i don't want to be part of that bubble
yeah
that's a that's a great quality
because i've broke out out of one bubble
i'm not going to fit into another
one of the best days of my life was when
i finally graduated from college and was
free to do whatever i wanted to do
rather than
what you were supposed to do exactly
what you had to do exactly and
just
going through that whole journey of
finding myself and
and struggling and and going from beauty
to art to to to business to literally
into like to different like aspects of
design
i was
i almost
almost lost my mind and it's not a bad
way it's a good thing i lost my mind i
was like there is so many fields and so
so little restrictions when you're done
with school
so why am i in a box why am i in that
bubble when i could be going out and
just
really expressing who i am yeah that
that spirit that that motivation and
inspiration combined with hard work
is how you do things exactly
and
i've watched that for my entire life my
my dad was
he was abandoned by his family he was
he was
i will tell you he was 13 years old in
libya and libya is a third world country
as well and now is a war-torn country
um
it's unfortunate but he was abandoned by
his family and so he had lived in the
streets for the majority of his life
until he was able to join the military
and
until then
he finally felt like
he was in somewhat like power of his
life and
with all of the experiences that he
experienced you know by joining the
military he started getting all this
culture and collecting all this culture
so he started getting into art and
to me
the fact that he ended at arts when he
started at a completely different field
it gives me
so much hope
so
much hope
it shows me that i can start somewhere
and end up somewhere completely
different
and you can use that inspiration of your
journey to really reach that final goal
that final point that will make you feel
like
you are
making a change in this world
and you're finally satisfied with
where you are and how you live
because
i think that satisfaction
is not gonna come
until i'm like 80 and i'm sitting in the
bed and i'm looking at my grandkids and
i'm like
i've done what my father has done for me
that's that's just what i want to be in
life like i know i'm going to tear up
right now but that's like yeah for me
too art was the best thing that ever
happened to me
the best thing
expression
at
being in a bubble in morocco
i couldn't express anything
thank you very much
yeah there were so many times in my life
where
i said to myself thank god i have
art when you're heartbroken over a
relationship when things are just not
going well
whenever whenever life wasn't working
out you realized you had art
and it saved me
over and over again it still does today
exactly and that's keeps you away from
things like drugs keeps you away from
bad relationships keeps you away from
all kinds of things it keeps you away
from things that are going to ruin your
life because at that moment when you
feel so restricted you you feel so
blocked and you feel like you have
no way of expressing what's inside
you you can finally like you can just be
there with what you love and be able to
let it all go without any consequences
because when you share with people or
you go out and you do drugs and or you
go out and you you like
lash out
in a physical space outside that stuff
will always affect you it will it's like
a ripple effect
but when you're
in your own zone in your own world
expressing
what's
deepest inside you
i don't know i've never felt to release
like that i've i've never i've done
therapy and i've never felt a release
like picking up a pen and paper
there's something about
that
instant transaction
that can't be expressed through any
other way like especially words
i can't tell you what my art's like and
i can't tell you why you shouldn't you
shouldn't be asked to
never you just do it exactly you're just
supposed to join
for you and me it sounds like it's your
way of communicating with the world
exactly and
it's the
it's literally the only way i found so
far
where it's worked yeah and it's not just
like for you it's fashion for me it's
visuals and maybe storytelling but for
it can be for a lawyer it can be
practicing law for a doctor it can be
being a doctor it can be so many
different things it's all art to me
exactly it's just what you're passionate
about what you love and doing what you
love and that's it yeah it's being able
to isolate yourself with whatever it is
that you love
and everything else just becomes a
nuisance a distraction yes exactly yes
that's exactly how i feel about you know
art and fashion and
everything like that
it's a
it's a world away from the world and
and it and sometimes yes of course they
overlap but it's the fact that you have
that safe space and the fact that you
can both get it to be completely alone
and interact with the world that you're
living in
is what really makes me like sane it's
what makes me know but it's also it's
also
a good sign that you you realize that
the wild side of you
that's that doesn't want to be conformed
by a school
is to be protected yes that's great yes
exactly because that's exactly what will
make you different and unique
and successful if you apply yourself yes
exactly
and yeah i mean
my life
has been since i was a kid
i've always been looked down on and you
know and
and even like i said name the problem
child
but even throughout i was growing i
never saw myself as the problem child
because i saw my spark
and that's what they call the problem
child
being different having that spark you
know having the ability to to look at my
teacher and be like are you sure you're
not wrong
and so they looked at me and it was a
little bit of like a
you know her ego type thing the teacher
kind of went through
because i don't think they've ever
really faced a
a child learning the alphabet and still
questioning
exactly why and how or or how do we
apply this to like different fields you
know like i was so
i was so curious and they tried to cap
that
yeah and the more they tried to cap it
the more
i blew up even more that's great
and if you can channel that into
something positive like you're doing yes
then it can really benefit your life
whereas otherwise it
manifests as as all kinds of other
problems exactly and you end up in jail
prison
addicted
so many things yeah so many things you
can channel into something positive
where you can become successful i'm
happy yes and i did have like a dark
really dark moment when i came here
because
i left morocco and i came here thinking
everything was going to get better and
as soon as i left like family turmoil uh
just happened to spark up and i wasn't
there to deal with the issues that were
going on and then me having to support
my sibling in going to college without
my my my father knowing and
so many little aspects that i felt like
i needed to grow
like 15 years in a year and
i was i was placed under
i was placed under such a spotlight from
my family that i felt like i had
i had no time to work on my school or
who i am or or anything i had to support
my older brother through college
using my own tuition money
you know and all of that and figure out
how to get more money by the time that
my tuition needs to be paid and pay my
rent and
and so i definitely went through a
depression i went through times where i
would cut i went through times where i
would think of suicide
but again i would kind of reflect back
and think
this is just another cap
it's another cat we am you've done this
for 18 years
why can't you do it now
you can
this is the biggest cap that i've gotten
this is the biggest cup i've gotten
to deal with yet and i'm still dealing
with it it's been
three years of like in and out of
depression
and during that time i also got a really
bad food poisoning so i lost almost like
20 pounds i went underweight
i had
two months where i couldn't sleep or eat
and so i went through this moment where
i was like i think this is the end of my
life
and
that almost like
kicked me so hard in the face because i
was like
what am i doing
what are you doing liam you've been
capped
capped yeah as a woman as an artist as a
as everything almost everything i've
experienced in my life i've been put
down and every time i had to break
through but did i break through enough
just enough to not be capped again
because
when i look back i'm like yes you did
breakthrough every time you were shut
down but
you should break through enough to just
cut it all out
be so strong in who you are and believe
in yourself
and
just go with your ideas and your style
and your flow
and with that there's going to be no
more caps because even when they try to
cap they're not going to find the right
lid
they're not going to find the right lid
they're going to try to it's not going
to work i'm going to escape all this all
this adversary adversity you're facing
will eventually make you so strong
that you'll you'll be
so well prepared for any obstacles you
come your way and you'll
you'll just
blow through it exactly and so now what
i've
literally figured out in my life is that
every pot has a shape
but i'm the only pot that don't gotta
shape
so you can't cap me can't put that lid
on top i'm sorry this is something i've
yes as a 20 year old i speak like i'm 35
but
being going through so much turmoil age
doesn't even matter anymore it really
doesn't it's it's the story it's it's
how you you use that story to your
benefits and
yes to do it today i was literally
sitting in the park and i was thinking
i don't know what i'm doing here but i
feel like it's the right spot
it's the right spot so i just sat down
and i was like
i feel like i'm doing the right thing
and and
and so i was i was just enjoying my life
and just enjoying what i was doing which
i haven't been doing you know i haven't
done in so long so just to sit at the
park and wear what i want to wear and
just do nothing
i think that was the last time i did
that was never and so
so for me it's like
i'm having an amazing time now because i
finally discovered that
ain't nobody stopping me
i feel
like inside i'm 30 something and i'm 21.
i got the whole world ahead of me the
whole world and in next two years i plan
to be
killing it
killing it changing the world i
i can't explain the journey that i've
been on but i'm trying the best that i
can so you can just express exactly what
and there's so many more like
smaller stories of like
you know
seeing death and appreciating life as
well and
that's also something that i grew up
with
growing up in morocco must be
you see things that
most people in the united states never
see yeah and it is like a very
progressed country but there are like a
lot of things that i feel like i've just
tumbled on
in my childhood that have shaped me to
be who i am right now i remember
the first time i saw somebody uh
deceased was
i'm gonna seven years old i remember uh
i was
walking on the beach
and it was a really beautiful day at my
beach house with my family we were
fortunate enough to have a beach house
and
i was i was walking down and it was
around 8 a.m i love waking up early so
i've always always done that and it was
such a safe beach i knew all my
neighbors for at least like miles and
miles on end
and so i was enjoying my day and
i see something on this end and this is
what i wrote my
essay on because it has changed me
forever i see something in the sand and
i see it's a round
it's a round black like
you know um
i don't know what they're called but the
the donuts
yes and inflatable and and so i'm
walking towards it and i i start seeing
something else and i
kind of get scared because it was a body
it was a body
so obviously i
as a curious child i come closer um
and it was a naked woman
she was like purple
i can still see her in my head
and
she had
a lot of bruise marks like a lot of
bruises
a lot neck
intimate areas
um chest
and i i saw that and i was like
i was changed forever
because that almost gave me an image of
who
and what women are in our world and in
morocco
she
she was ignored the police never did
anything about it um
they never even looked into it never
even had
um
never even had like a autopsy done
um because i i wanted to know i asked my
parents they said they just let it go
they let it go and to me the reason was
because she was a woman
she was a woman
somebody killed her
murdered her
put her on an inflatable
and set her out into the ocean
and nobody gave a [ __ ]
and as a seven-year-old
i knew what world i was going into
unjust
for people
for my gender
and for my country too
because once i leave my country i'm just
i'm just an immigrant
i'm a third world person
and even in my country i can't feel safe
so all of these things were against me
that's why i grew up so opinionated i
think
it's like
i have a role i have to have a role
um
and that was my earliest death uh
my mom went after because
people started crowding up because i was
just like staring at her i was standing
there speechless i had no no emotion no
sound no nothing came out of my mouth i
was standing there like this
because
what do you say as a seven-year-old do
you scream do you
do you run away
do you watch
i i didn't know i never experienced i've
never seen a dead body
you know so
i was just watching and eventually
people started crowding up and my mom
just grabbed me hid my eyes
i remember doing this pulling her arm
her hand down and just looking even
longer because i couldn't accept it i
was like i need to look i need this
image to be burned in my head
because
guess what i'm that woman
i'm gonna be that woman i will always be
that woman
forever
i will never have a moment where i'm not
my gender
they will always look at me that way
it's unjust the world is unjust
and so i live my life like that i live
my life thinking
i need to like i need to break to the
ceiling like that's that's what i've
literally lived my life for and i'm
still living my life for
and funny enough i experienced more
death along the way i've
i've
grown grown up with the same
25 people since i was three years old
most of them were my neighbors some were
a little farther but it was the same
people year after year and
when i was in ninth grade
my first friend passed away he had
epilepsy
and
he was in a pool and he drowned
that took a piece of
me away because i was like
we're young and
you're creating such beautiful
connections and they're taken away from
you
that's another thing that
i could relate to the woman because she
was
she had no choice she was taken away by
somebody else
and i know that my friend wasn't either
but it's the concept of just being taken
away that
i was
struggling with
shortly after a year after my other
friend passes away from cancer
my knee cancer specifically
is weird for me it's usually bone or
it's specifically his kneecap and
it killed me because
this person i used to
go to have play dates with and
and see their parents and i grew up with
them in their homes and
all the homes they've moved to and like
so again i've lost something that i've
cared about
so i had to like almost live my life
with the idea that hey
you're gonna lose a lot
a lot
and as a woman
you're gonna lose even more
and
it sucks to say
but i'm ready to lose i'm ready to lose
people i'm ready to lose
myself and what i'm doing
but i feel like
loss
it only only occurs when it's absolutely
necessary
everything should be celebrated and
that's what i've grown up to believe
it's like i started with hating hating
losing things and people but here i am
accepting and using it to my benefit
almost yeah
thank you so much for sharing your your
interesting story
and i wish you the best of luck with
your
with your art and school and everything
else thank you thank you very much of
course
you